we've had a historically low mortgage
rates so everyone got these crazy low
mortgage rates of two and a half three
percent three and a half percent and
then now interest rates on savings
accounts are like four percent so like
I'm never paying off my mortgage you're
an idiot if you pay it for mortgage
early dude this is a money making scheme
go invest in the stock market instead of
paying off your mortgage and I'm going
where are they getting guaranteed
returns of 10 in the stock market now we
say long term the stock market has seen
10 to 12 on average
but assuming that in a given year it's
not going to be I don't know negative 18
like it was in 2021 that is a wild
starry-eyed approach to finances